good maybe a welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight back when he was still a star on
MSNBC and CNN was still touting his
presidential candidacy this show was
warning America about the creepy porn
lawyer now his crimes had been exposed
and he could be disbarred a lawyer who
was pushing that effort will join us in
just a few minutes with details but
first tonight let's begin with a thought
experiment what if the Republican
leadership here in Washington had
bothered to learn the lessons of the
2016 election what if they'd cared
enough to do that what if they had
understood and embraced the economic
nationalism that was at the heart of
Donald Trump's presidential campaign
what would the world look like now two
and a half years later
well for starters Republicans in
Congress would regularly be saying
things like this quote I'm deeply
grateful for the opportunities America
has given me but the giant American
corporations who control our economy
don't seem to feel the same way they
certainly don't act like it sure these
companies wave the flag but they have no
loyalty or allegiance to America
Levi's is an iconic American brand but
the company operates only 2% of its
factories here Dixon Ticonderoga maker
of the famous number two pencil has
moved almost all of its pencil
production to Mexico and China and
General Electric recently shut down an
industrial engine factory in Wisconsin
and shipped the jobs to Canada the list
goes on and on these quote American
companies show only one real loyalty to
the short-term interests of their
shareholders a third of whom are foreign
investors if they can close up an
American Factory and ship jobs overseas
to save a nickel that's exactly what
they will do abandoning loyal American
workers and hollowing out American
cities along the way politicians love to
say they care about American jobs but
for decades those same politicians have
cited free-market principles and refused
to intervene in markets on behalf of
American workers and of course they
ignore those same supposed principles
and intervene regularly to protect the
interests of multinational corporations
an international capital the result
millions of good jobs lost overseas and
a generation of stagnant wages growing
inequality and sluggish economic growth
if Washington wants to put a stop to
this it can if we want faster growth
stronger American industry and more good
American jobs then our government should
do what other leading nations do and act
aggressively to achieve those goals
instead of catering to the financial
interests of companies with no
particular allegiance to America the
truth is that Washington policies not
unstoppable market forces are a key
driver of the problems American workers
face from our trade agreements to our
tax code we have encouraged companies to
invest abroad ship jobs overseas and
keep wages low all in the interest of
serving multinational companies and
international capital with no
particularly to the United States it's
becoming easier and easier to shift
capital and jobs from one country to
another that's why our government has to
care more about defending and creating
American jobs than ever before not less
we can navigate the changes ahead if we
embrace economic patriotism and make
American workers our highest priority
rather than a continuing to cater to the
interests of companies and people with
no allegiance to America end quote now
let's say you regularly vote Republican
ask yourself what part of the statement
you just heard did you disagree with was
there a single word that seemed wrong to
you probably not here's the depressing
part nobody you voted for said that or
would ever say it Republicans in
Congress can't promise to protect
American industries they wouldn't dare
to do that it might violate some
principle of Austrian economics they
might make the Koch brothers mad it
might alienate the libertarian
ideologues who to this day fund most
Republican campaigns so no a Republican
did not say that
sadly instead the words you just heard
are from embrace herself here senator
Elizabeth Warren of Massachusetts it's
true
yesterday Warren released what she
called her plan
for economic patriotism amazingly that's
pretty much what it is economic
patriotism there's not a word about
identity politics in the document
they're no hysterics about gun control
or climate change there's no lecture
about the plight of transgender illegal
immigrants is just pure old-fashioned
economics how to preserve good-paying
American jobs even more remarkable many
of warren's policy prescriptions make
obvious sense
she says the US government should buy
American products when it can and of
course it should she says we need more
workplace apprenticeship programs
because four-year college degrees aren't
right for everyone well that's true
she says that taxpayers ought to benefit
from the research and development that
they pay for and yet she writes quote we
often see American companies take that
research and use it to manufacture
products overseas like Apple did with
the iPhone the companies get rich and
American taxpayers have subsidized the
creation of low-wage foreign jobs end
quote and so on she sounds like Donald
Trump at his best so who is this
Elizabeth Warren you asked well not the
race hustling gun grabbing abortion
extremists who thought you knew well
unfortunately Elizabeth Warren is still
all of those things - and that's exactly
the problem not just with Elizabeth
Warren but with American politics in
Washington almost nobody speaks for the
majority of voters you're either a
libertarian zealot controlled by the
bank's yammering on about
entrepreneurship and how we need to cut
entitlements that's one side of the
aisle or worse you're some decadent
trust-fund socialists who wants to ban
passenger cars and give Medicaid to
illegal aliens that's the other side
what there isn't is a caucus that
represents where most Americans actually
are nationalists on economics fairly
traditional on the social issues imagine
a politician who wanted to make your
health care cheaper but wasn't
ghoulishly excited about partial-birth
abortion imagine someone who genuinely
respected the nuclear family and
sympathized with the culture of rural
America but at the same time was willing
to take your side against rapacious
credit card companies bleeding you dry
at 35 percent interest would you vote
for someone like that
thank gosh of course you would who
wouldn't that candidate would be elected
in a landslide every single time and yet
that candidate is the opposite of pretty
much everyone currently serving in our
Congress our leadership class remains
resolutely libertarian committed to the
rhetoric of markets when it serves them
utterly libertine on questions of
culture Republicans will lecture you
about how payday loan scams are a
critical part of our market economy then
that work to make it easier for your
kids to smoke weed because hey freedom
Democrats will not in total agreement
they're on the same page just last week
the Trump administration announced an
innovative new way to protect American
workers from the ever cascading tidal
wave of cheap third-world labor flooding
this country until the maxeen government
stops pushing illegal aliens north over
our border we will impose tariffs on all
Mexican goods that we import now that's
the kind of thing you might propose to
protect your country if you cared about
your people the Democrats of course
opposed it they don't even pretend to
care about the American people anymore
here's what Republicans said look I
think it's safe to say you've talked to
all of our members we're not fans of
tariffs we're still hoping that this can
be avoided we're not fans of tariffs
imagine a more supercilious more out of
touch more infuriating response well you
can't because there isn't one
in other words says Mitch McConnell the
idea may work in practice but we're
against it because it doesn't work in
theory that's the Republican Party 2019
no wonder they keep losing they deserve
it will they ever change